so we've come to the end of our poster
competition we were all really thrilled
by the range of posters and how much
trouble that people had gone to and what
good ideas they had they really produced
some very clever adaptations of real
posters as well as some completely
original ones as well the way we judged
it was that there was a panel of 16 or
17 people who voted then all the votes
were counted up secretly and the weight
came out was quite surprising we had
three people in second place and one
marker head we had an overall winner
let's get down to business who actually
won I've got a list here of the prize
winners I have a very funny name it's
usually pronounced wrong so i probably
will pronounce many of these names wrong
as well that so you have my sympathy in
advance the first of the three second
prize winners is Amy Martin and you can
see her poster here it's really very
nice the second second prize winner is
Anna in Armstrong and here's her poster
the third one is from Powell Remy and
here is the poster
and our overall winner is Katya Virtanen
from Finland who had a really subtle
poster based on the film ET very
minimalist very clever and lots of test
tubes so what are the prizes well each
of the prize winner gets a tie I had
some difficulty by managed to sign the
mall Katya as the overall winner also
gets the gold watch or the gold-plated
watch which Brady and Neil and Darren
managed to plate and wreck at the same
time we wish you all great success in
your chemistry and look forward to your
entries the next time we have a
competition